you know I'll face right stop
close your eyes and arch and stretch
gorgeous that's it
hopefully get both your eyes in the Sun
that's gorgeous
actually eyes down darling
I'm just trying to think here I'm
thinking you're doing something lying
down here now and kind of these [ __ ]
and rest your face just here bring it on
running mate
so guys you don't mind this I tell you
to put that the ad [ __ ] that's it see
more grafting like hey babe
so guys both close your eyes now let's
close should get that off you that's
better
perfect position there love it lighting
is perfect on you
that's awesome don't move just slightly
overlapped with the flute messages there
yeah
but gorgeous guys love that beautiful
look at me for a second
look at me I'm gonna catch like get that
done it hold it there
one two three
separate your face is a little bit too
just there so I can see and look at his
lips looking at his lips
cool man is your perfect light because
you got some light in the back of you
then in the front so I just want your
hands in your in your pockets yeah let's
do those top buttons up just want you to
lean your body forward like this and
then turn your face towards a light
that's good so just your eyes at me
really cool yeah that's awesome
I want to look back at your parents and
you are going to watch them do this is
this is basically how a 51 year marriage
kiss this is what it will look like so
let me see a kiss of a couple being
married for 51 years go on out oh there
we go that's what I wanted you be as
happy as that in 51 years that's a
beautiful thing that's gorgeous guys and
mum and dad for hitch touching and look
into dad and giggling that's it yeah
Angela we're giggling we're loving we're
about to marry the man of our dreams the
man of our dreams but actually how long
you guys been married for 36 years I
want to see what a 36 year old loving
your your your soul mates kiss looks
like so look back at your parents let's
see a kiss go on
there we go
all these guys kiss my porn stars I love
em look at
see now I have an exact picture in my
mind of what your ass looks like it I
mean it looks like plastic bring me all
those out that is awesome hold there
like that for me
and either me gorgeous
Hey look back at mommy look back look at
them chin up chin up and
okay ready in the can of three with a
sprayer up in the air lots of giggles
one to go
okay turn back at him and forehead such
a cute little giggle at each other guys
crack it up ice down as you're doing it
darling
giggly that's it beautiful and yeah yeah
yeah so romantic okay look at each other
guys what okay Bethany lean back a
little bit I catch it up a little bit
that's it I look over your shoulder back
this way darling look this way
over my shoulder ever giggling we're
loving each other
all right I'll tell you what if you can
get one two three just give it a check
up in the air give me a second
one two go for it so what I want you to
do that guys is I want your eyes to be
at that way you get a spot
that's it crack it up guys
that's it there stay stay stay put look
now look at look at her leaning to her
kick your heel out darling other way and
point the toe are you down down down
down down that's beautiful
chin right up chin right up and crack it
up laughing close your eyes darling
I can the can of three then this way you
keep your face towards the Sun oh that
they hold it ready
big smile big laugh stuff and they're
ready one Cheers
without your breasts darling on the
glass a bit more trying to make a foggy
foggy look there
okay guys 100 ISO I want a shallow
depth-of-field come eliminate all that
crap 2.8 I'm going to shoot with a
daylight white balance to be quite
brighter than me gray right
all right beautiful beautiful darling
holiday sir the girl a little yeah could
you tell me what but I need a bit of a
laugh I know that sounds funny it's on
the can of three aren't you looking at
my hand that's it so no smile really
suffer record beautiful gorgeous hold it
adjust adjust again for that and just
sort of bend your arms a little bit
that's it and then turn your face left
chin down and then lean forward and arch
your back with your face forward again
that beautiful
ashes at beautiful amazing oh I'm with
the network you understand when you see
the photos how's it feeling to the back
to me firstly we lift all right there
you go put your arms right around
give her a cheap little kiss on the
forehead there mate and she's laughing
hysterically thinking what the hell are
we doing here for John Rother rainy
Valley okay squeeze in tight I want you
to do I want you to pretend like you've
got champagne okay let me squeeze in
tight the guy's lean this way like a
turn to each other guys look each other
like you just here so just tell it down
a bit
dollar down snuggling in a bit of giggle
there guys lean forward and give her a
kiss on the cheek
and close your eyes knowing close your
eyes now you're kissing him at here is
there go on the other side in between
them each other like softly softly dim
it down
one just one more
and then this hand it's all much your
adjusting and looking at that way
everyone they did and bring it hold you
bun basically yeah and then bring that
hand up a bit yeah beautiful
that's a beautiful chin up to one and
turn your face this week that's a dummy
chin down and lean forward towards the
light of it
that's the antenna face more right and
your shoulders
and mum and dad got nice and close lucky
just a better kiss forgiving giggle dad
sit come over I'll take all the other
home home one to go and Jerry's gonna
try an impossible shot from here Jerry
he's got his ridiculously impossible
shot in one try so now because it's
never good enough we're gonna go back
even further just see if he can make it
from here okay so those of you who've
been following us on our tour and you
you know them on now in a mission to try
to find something that Jerry can't do
let's try basketball we tried darts
we've got a bull's eye in one and then
we're in a hotel mr. Hyatt
in where
we're in Kentucky Kentucky a great
Torchic right in Kentucky and we found a
pool table rid of this hotel so no magic
Jerry to try to play hole and use
something that know what else to do so
what are you going to try to do to
impress us okay I'm gonna try it with my
eyes closed
Chloe's you close your eyes what was
peaceful three questions with your eyes
closed all right hold on hold on
okay
let's do it do it so guys when you're
looking into those lips soften the eyes
work your way to the screen it just a
little any light that you're in love
with that really being in love unless
you want to be so good I'm hooking you
up I'm working here darling
give me pops up think about it nice and
soft guys
ha
ah
all right let's see if this is a fluke
all right it's very important it's very
important for me to try this okay this
is the name of the game right I'm going
to hit three cushions and then this ball
goes in here I'll do with my eyes closed
okay you ready here we are it's all good
okay
in fact I look at you you spits Harmon
here I don't know sir don't ask me to do
that again what do you do with it you
hang on it's water I said especially on
the fairy cake